North Korea is warning the US could face
what it calls an unimaginable strike at
any time a new statement from Pyongyang
criticizes ongoing joint military drills
between the u.s. and South Korea it says
the two countries are war mongers and
the root cause of a nuclear war New York
Times opinion page communist Nicholas
Kristof spent five days inside North
Korea and wrote a series of articles
about his experiences he discovered
North Korea is galvanizing its people to
expect a nuclear war with the u.s.
Nikolas joins us here at the table good
morning good morning this is your third
trip to North Korea right that's correct
and so how was this different from what
you've seen in the past so it was very
different
I mean North Korea is always a bizarre
place and there's always a certain
amount of over-the-top rhetoric but this
time the country has really galvanized
for war there's constant talk about
missile attacks on the US there are
billboards around the country showing
missiles destroying the US Capitol
destroying the US flag there is
discussion about how a nuclear war with
the u.s. is inevitable and maybe most
striking about how North Korea will
defeat the u.s. in this nuclear war has
not only survivable but but actually
winnable they're convinced they they
would win if a war took place
astonishingly they are convinced that
that they would win and that the u.s.
would then retreat ignominiously from
the korean peninsula from japan from
asia and kim jongmin would unite the
korean peninsula are they so confident
Nick well I mean of course it's always
very difficult to distinguish what they
say versus what they fail on but they
have a huge network of underground
tunnels and underground fortifications
and their narrative is also that they
have repeatedly defeated the US and the
Korean War in a series of incidents
across the the DMZ and so and there's
always a danger of course the dictators
come to believe their own propaganda and
I'm nervous if that is what is happening
right now were you nervous and afraid
while you were there yourself but you
knew you had handlers the whole time it
didn't seem like you were able to move
freely as you have been in the past
that's right I mean look reporting in
North Korea you were always very
constrained
but in the past I was able to stay in
the center of the city in a hotel to
walk around this time the North Korean
Foreign Ministry had handlers that just
clung to me like a limpet they kept me
at a guarded foreign ministry compound
in the rice paddies outside of town and
I thought oh this is to protect the
North Koreans from my vigorous
questioning but no it turns out that
they were there to protect me from the
security services who might not be on
board with having an American journalist
in town and that was so that was kidnap
you and take you yeah you know I don't
think it was so much that the security
forces would suddenly grab me I think it
was more of a concern that I might
engage in some kind of mischief and then
the security forces would grab me and
then there would be a problem we know
North Korea is probably the biggest
national security test that that Trump
will face when I was there in May and
interviewed president moon the new
president of South Korea he talked about
opening up a bilateral dialogue Trump
talked about that on the campaign he
said talking sitting knee to knee with
the North Korean leader Kim Jong on any
sense that that dialogue can or will
happen one of the sad thing is is that
the the doves if you will the people
trying to find an exit ramp in North
Korea just like those in Washington seem
to be marginalized and so the hardliners
seemed to be ascendant both in the North
Korean capital Pyongyang and in
Washington so I was struck that the
North Koreans were not very interested
in in talks so that's interesting
because you know President Obama's
policy was one of strategic patience
right there wasn't this bellicose
rhetoric some people criticize that as
in letting the North Koreans build up
this weaponry but now you have this very
tough talk from the president's mouth
and on Twitter how are the North Koreans
using that so I think that the president
Trump's talk has been counterproductive
it was striking that the North Koreans
are leveraging it for their own
propaganda
so your average North Korea knows
nothing about otto warmbier for example
though that doesn't penetrate they know
all about president Trump's threat to
totally destroy North Korea because it
fits into their narrative but this is
the other part of it we did a story with
David Newton Felder who was in North
dozens of times and he talked about all
of North Korea's not kim jeong-hoon I
mean there's we're talking about
millions of people there too who don't
necessarily don't know about all of this
and and wouldn't necessarily agree with
what their leader is doing you know it's
very hard to know what ordinary North
Koreans think but and in North Korea you
don't get a very good sense of that but
I must say talking to defectors you get
the sense that the mind control
controlling every bit of information
having a speaker in people's homes to to
bring in propaganda not having radio
dials that that works pretty well to get
people to essentially believe in the
regime except closer to the Chinese
board or closer to the Chinese border
they do hear alternative truths and they
begin to question things as I try to
live their lives avoiding nuclear war
and we're glad you're back safely so am
I so is my wife yes thank you